and this is the connection that i think
we can talk about now it's basically the
connection between
enlightenment and health or awakening
and health
so the more in a sense that you
recognize
the the
unity of all being the unity of all
existence that
deep interconnectedness of all and also
that source that you come from that you
are
that we are that and that the more that
you really
embody that that the impenetrable
peace and the causeless joy and you
basically
stay in that state and you make art from
that state
the healthier you are on all your health
biomarkers
yes um uh you you touch on something
that's uh
you know what's uh interesting is that
illness medicine always demands
proof right and that's because they're
based on population-based thinking right
so
when you're and they're you're talking
about quantity the quantity of people
that have survived because see they're
after survival rates right
there that's that's their measure the
the measure of the success
of any intervention that they do is
after survival rate so they're after
quantity and for me i'm after quality
right what's the quality uh uh one of
the things that i learned early on
um in uh medical informatics when i was
uh
uh doing you know uh research on
on how much is the value of life and uh
you know in dollars you know how much is
one life worth and all that yeah
we we do those kinds of research those
are done right
um you don't know that the the actuaries
of the people that provide you with life
insurance those are all computed
and those are all known right but um
when you
when you look at all all of this stuff
it's like
what is the quality of your life now and
the thing that i i learned there is that
there are outcomes that are worse than
death
right and we don't like to admit that
that there are outcomes
worse than death but that is already the
finding of studies
what in the 1990s right uh
we we know that and and uh you know only
the most ignorant of us
would of doctors would say well i have i
have the
uh i took an oath well you know that's
that's just for hollywood
right um so we
we already have established a kind of
thing so
we now have to turn our focus on what's
the quality of life that we're living
and the quality of life that you live is
actually inside you
right yeah yeah yeah remember john
kobatson
wrote a famous book right wherever you
go there you are
so um so what's what's that status of
the default mode network inside your
brain are you know
are you too self-referential all the
time um
but for me it's like uh what is uh you
know how do you live life with a sense
of equanimity
and um i was asked this question one
time
uh is uh by a psychiatrist he said dr
ted you know your health optimization
medicine model which is
seven pillars is just brilliant but how
do you include
spirituality right in health
optimization
and i said oh you know it's really very
simple
right um uh you know that the
dmt is called the spirit molecule
so just give the person dmt and
you solve the spiritual imbalance
it's the fastest way to just
obliterate the ego obliterate the ego
and
and just melt melt right into the
infinite consciousness just
melt right into it and then hopefully
you can re-baseline
the big thing is to read baseline after
entheogenic experience is unleashing the
divine within
but then can you re-baseline to that
level
well is actually done
through practice like exactly exactly or
um or other practices that actually
um point out to you the illusoriness of
the self
right i you know ego is a very
heavily laden term you know it does
freudian it's your sense of self
importance
but uh so i i tend to use this
self-referential system
more than i use the ego but people
understand the ego because
it's everything from which everything is
centered right
but that center is an illusion right
it's it's uh
it's just created by the brain it's uh
it's part of uh
what evolved to give us a sense of
continuity but it's also the source of
our suffering
and if you take a look at our website
uh for you know transcriptions is a
brand of my company called smarter not
harder
right and uh if you take a look at our
mission there is to decrease suffering
in ourselves and to decrease suffering
in others
knowing that there is no other exactly
beautiful
so so so we come to a definition of
what's suffering
you know for me suffering is really very
simple
um you know in in in common parlance for
me suffering is
identifying with the self or you know
getting lost with the thought
you know you think the thought is you
right like uh
so uh there is someone that's owning the
experience
obsessed it's got some of the layers of
identity that we
that we've put
ever peeled off we gotta to feel the
source
to feel it and live from that source
yeah and and for me you know i'm i have
less grandiose plans uh you know
uh i have a simple definition of
enlightenment which is you know the
cessation
of suffering and which is suffering the
source of suffering is
the ego which is an illusion anyway that
is the clings to
or is averse to certain things so it
wants this doesn't want that
once this is one path and soon all of
those once once once
accumulate right you want more profits
you want more
therefore you're going to pollute the
oceans more and therefore you're going
to use
um child labor more therefore you're
going to
to a traffic humans more you know all in
the name of one one
one right so and therefore for me that
is suffering you know uh
if you the clinging and aversion of the
ego is the root of suffering
right also says
yes yes there's a there's a balance
here and i'm curious how you align with
this idea
it's called like the dreamed symphony in
the sense that
the infinite consciousness creates the
dreamed
reality that is that is this and then
there's the
multiverse which is all of the dreamed
realities this is just one observers and
there's
many other observers happening an an
infinite amount of illusory finity
in a sense that is happening and so
here you here here we have this this
um dimensionless singularity
that is indivisible and it's
indescribable the the the dow that can
be named is not the eternal dao
okay so we have that and then now we are
the
um the dream symphony and so here's the
symphony that's happening
now in the symphony i'm playing the
violin
but you're playing the trombone and then
someone else is playing the clarinet and
someone else is playing the cello
and we're all playing different melodies
and different harmonies
and people that are playing out of tune
are people like you described that are
suffering they're still suffering
they're still
in the service to self mentality and
people that are playing in tune
are playing in the service to other
mentality
everything's in service they're they've
they've a clear
gnosis of the divine
that they are and what and what's going
on they're very clear
seer of truth consciousness how do you
resonate with
that dreamed symphony analogy ben
that's [ __ ] heavy
i mean the one thing that i you know i i
you know i i i i told you it's just with
with friends here
and one thing that i usually totally
inject into all of these things is
levity
you can never be too [ __ ] serious
about
anything right yes and you know i i
you know my pedigree is in neuroscience
and i'm still a neuroscientist and even
i'm a physician you know
even in in as a physician i still deal
with the brain
so let's bring down
uh so for me right
right now we're trying to there's a 20
million
uh dollar prize now the templeton to to
um
uh to uh uh elicit the
the uh mechanism of consciousness right
and one is the causal um
uh model which is the
integrated information theory right and
one is the causal model
um or the non-causal model which is the
global workspace theory
among others right you know because my
interest
in this is still in in consciousness and
then there's of course you know
philosophers you know that you know they
say well maybe it's a pansei kissim
whether or not it's inherent or
immersion fans like something or you
don't know
who wins right but you know
my thing is this is fun and this is the
answer to
your question yes my answering question
ever since i was a kid all the way to
now or so
my first experience with ayahuasca for
example
it's as if a rug was pulled from under
me as a strict
scientist you know just looking at the
world with this
you know and then you it's if a rug is
pulled out under you
and suddenly that there are dimensions
out there
that were unavailable for you before
right yeah so so uh and then it's easier
for you
to actually um realize
that the self is an illusion you know
and then now
physics is saying that space-time we're
losing space-time to be
it's an illusion right yeah and
we we now have i have people saying that
all we're doing in this world is like we
are just a user interface with
fitness functions the donald huffman
right
uh we evolved we see an apple we see
this only because
that's you know that's our user
interface
in order to to to execute our programs
or survival and reduction
right and uh so uh
but but for me the site guys the spirit
of everything else is a [ __ ] game
yeah you know you when you you best
enjoy the game you know when
when you um an mmorpg massive
multiplayer online role-playing game
yeah this is what i this is what i say
you know
um it's very difficult to convince
people unless they have done programming
that
what you believe in is not necessarily
true
right right so but the the biggest punch
that i give them is that when you were a
kid you believed you believed in santa
claus
right and then you were able to shed
that belief that's right
other beliefs are harder to shed
yeah right and when you're programming
for example if you set a global variable
if you said that god is true
then do the following if jesus christ is
true then do the following
if if you know gatama buddha is true
then
do the following so you could see that
you know whatever it is that's set in
there that's right it's
yeah it's it's it's programmatic right
it's super programmatic
but but that but that's hard for us to
accept
right it's easier if you take an
integral
view so when when you when you embrace
all that is and especially all eight
billion of these
individual players and what they see as
true as their scripts
if you have anything that's important
ask their script scripts
but the thing is they cannot see beyond
the script
if we can augment their
awareness beyond the script to the
integral
embrace of this beautiful mystery and
expressing unique gifts then we are into
that more harmonious world our hearts
know is possible
yeah that's why can i combine some
molecules
that can balance the default mode
network in the past past not
past positive network in such a way
right that it is evident to you that
there needs to be no owner of the
experience
right that there um that it is there
only so that it provides
its continuity for you to have a story
every day because
that's what allowed you to survive in
evolution right
so it's embracing that
but going beyond that right
and when we notice that
i i i tell people this that's why i i
tell people
you know all of us should be educated
after evolutionary biology evolution
psychology
we should be educated in evolutionary
game theory we don't realize that much
of our behavior
is dictated by that you know by zero
some dynamics yeah yeah why is it why is
the tit for that game why is it
successful all the time
you know and so on like but people will
go wow those are very difficult concepts
right
we need to tell better stories which
links us to the very beginning when we
tell better stories
hard it's hard to tell it's hard to tell
engaging stories in science right unless
you engage them and when
when well well we have to tell the story
the big metaphysical story
that is like in a sense like the harry
potter
of of you know like that like when we
can do that
then we can really inspire that
awakening for example you know um
right now you know we don't distinguish
when we're teaching kids
we don't distinguish between you know
teaching them religion versus teaching
them spirituality which are two
different things
yeah right we just shove in them and the
same
in these types of of religious neurosis
and they
end up having the same religious
neurosis
there's a very clear baby in the bath
water that we can
lift up and yeah
you know it requires a lot of good
stories told like
a lot of education yeah it requires a
lot well or
or what we can do is we can say okay how
can we take that what looks like a lot
of education
how can we compress that down pareto
efficient
into a couple of you know stories that
can
really awaken people i think we can do
that and that's pretty much what
not only this project um is that we'll
be oh
i i don't know i'm kidding yeah yeah
yeah yeah
but but no but this is why we are so
passionate also about the
space of um you know what like los
angeles
is doing with able to um
put together like the best animated
content
as well like why is you know pixar's
like inside out so popular or why
is um like rick and morty so popular in
that sense can we make it
into you know or like spongebob
squarepants for like the the kids
like how can we tell a story that so
deeply or like game of thrones and harry
potter
that's so deeply interwoven with
metaphysics though
um and that animation and storytelling
that's what we're passionate about in
2021
yeah you you you can also do the flip
side
right yes tell what is that what is my
my my
my friends know that i have an allergy
to stories because
they have always [ __ ] us up you know
if they're just
we are predisposed to stories that's why
we have all of these conspiracy theories
we were born to gossip and and so on
um you can also do the flip side
uh like we can teach
uh children to meditate earlier
you have a practice earlier in a
neuroscientific way right
here is how you observe the contents of
your consciousness right
that's part of what i'm describing in
terms of metaphysical stories
yeah yeah conserving the contents of
your consciousness
right early right yes
realizing
attention itself is another arising in
consciousness
so you see all of these arising
consciousness
and especially when you teach them to
kids before they develop
that that uh hardened sense of ego
ego i want this i don't want that i want
you
is they have this skill to take a look
at their desires and aversions and say
okay
should will i follow this desire or will
i follow will will i
get rid of this because i'm averse to it
a meta
consciousness yeah there is a pause that
happens
right before they actually act
there's that and in that pause the
entire destiny of
your life outcome in the world it
happens
yeah yes because uh maybe
it's you're gonna scream and yell at
someone who is going to
be you know the most influential figure
in your life and you lose it
right so so it gives you that that uh
you know it gives it stops you from
being reactive
into being responsive yeah and all it
takes
is being able to examine and for me it's
just a simple skill it's
it's difficult it's a difficult skill
that's why you can turn it into a mental
game
right uh of of uh being able to identify
your thoughts
investigation into the nature of your
being and
rupert spyra uses a very good modern day
analogy which is the simple
screen because if you think about that
infinite consciousness as your being as
that screen
and then having all of the different
cravings and aversions and scenes that
come up of the
illusory multidisci multiplicity and
diversity of objects and people
as as the as the scenes in the screen
in the movie that you realize that you
are that blissful
eternal infinite screen that's always
having these different
um slices of the movie so i
yeah you're right though that that first
principle at the young age you know
there's so many indigenous cultures
around the world
like the baby in their bathwater is the
fact that they have what you described
which is that depth of of truth that
depth of interconnection that depth of
unity
that depth of understanding the nature
of their own
mind and you know buddha was one of the
best
uh indicators and adi shankara was
another
massive one ramana maharshi these they
were excellent adam
at that investigation so and and
i mean infants are are fantastic they're
great until we [ __ ] them up
right because they are
evolutionarily and uh and uh
biologically programmed right
and then we begin the sociocultural
programming with education
you know uh with um uh uh education with
what the pair how the parents raise them
with uh uh
you know the the environment that
they're in so they're continuously
getting programmed and yes uh in fact
what one of the things that i um
uh interesting so the script being the
most open and integral and understanding
the nature of mind and reality at the
youngest
age that's great yeah and and and uh
also you know aside from from i said
going going the opposite
uh it's teaching kids you know how to
examine the contents of your
consciousness
and why they need to do so it's an
essential skill
that will not make them suffer in the
future exactly right because they know
that they're just arising in
consciousness right and the other thing
is when it's too late for you what i say
is that
um you know when you're 21 22 years old
or whatever
just go out and
and try to examine all of the beliefs
that were placed in there
by your parents by your siblings by your
teachers and
everything and see if they're still
working for you
you know uh all the lines of code
yeah yeah those those those those may
not be yours
right yeah as i say you know you can set
something to false
you can or my favorite is if you don't
need the variable anymore you put a
semicolon
to it yeah archived archive some code
and
update that with some new lines that are
more integral
yeah yes and then varying
that if you're still all older it's like
what kind of molecules can we use
in order to break through that right so
you have
you have a psilocybin you have mdma
you know you have all of this things
that can break through
which is you know they're used
therapeutically but they're also
consciousness-raising molecules you know
they are non-addicting
consciousness-raising molecules they're
not addicting because they don't raise
their
dopamine at all right yeah we know the
mechanism
we know the mechanism for addiction
right so so there's no more reason why
they say oh these are
because they constitution they won't
yeah they're back
hacking your script i i don't know of
anyone who
would like to take uh ayahuasca for fun
right
yeah we do it we do it to hack our
script
that's why we do it yeah although you
know
i hacked ayahuasca to my version of it
called pharmaca because i didn't want to
vomit
you know yeah continue vomiting but
these are
the these are the kinds of of things
that are
available you know um on the flip side
of
telling stories is you know educating
children that
teaching them how to to meditate and uh
you know
and making it a practice and making it a
habit for younger people to examine the
contents of their consciousness right
for us it's difficult but if you start
them young it's easy for them
because it's like seeing your optic
blind spot as sam harris likes to say
you know once it's pointed out to you
you cannot
you know not remember seeing it right
and then uh there's this
period where there's a time we should
examine what beliefs are in there
and you know and then we have now this
uh
um psychedelics that allow us to
investigate our mind
and uh allow us to change uh our scripts
and so on
and for me it's as i like to say those
are like
bodybuilding steroids now you use them
only for a while and then after that you
will have to do the exercises yourself
off cycle yes you have to have exactly
and and that's how you know for for me
like yes we're advancing in the world
and and so on but
are we alleviating the suffering of
people
so yes we have all of this high-tech
stuff and we have all of this biometrics
and so on and so forth
but fundamentally you know i'm not even
saying
anything about happiness you know we're
not wired for happiness
world for survival and reproduction
happiness is an inside job
but for me happiness is not suffering so
so if we can teach it's a it's a skill
that can be learned right um observing
the contents and
not being identifying as you said not
identifying
with the ego or not identifying with the
self-referential system
and knowing that things just arise you
know these are just
neural networks that fire you know as i
like to say
as a neural network guy you know when
you see something
your visual neural network fires when
you hear something
your auditory neural network fires you
know and
it is in the same space where your
uh thoughts arise they're also just
neural networks firing
where your emotions arise your limbic
system uh neural networks are firing
they're all just neural networks firing
and if you could see that
that when when they fire in such a way
that there's
it seems that there is someone
orchestrating them
that's where we actually get [ __ ] up
right when they when we when we when we
uh
when we um begin to own that we can
control these things that's why the most
difficult thing in meditation right is
like i want to control my thoughts now
you can't you have allowed them to go
right and see that they disappear they
appear in the same
space of consciousness as everything
else as what you see what you hear
you know what you feel you know the
pressure in your body
the concept of you having a face and so
on
they're all appearing in the same
consciousness
space as where thought arises where
emotion arises
and it's a skill you know that can be
taught
to be able to see the arisings of those
and you could see suffering decrease
and when suffering decreases then you
could see
creativity arises right
because you're not craving for something
anymore
right you are you are in equanimity
as i tell people i don't like
extreme happiness and deep whirlpools of
sadness
i just like you know uh gentle waves
of things um so so when you learn
when you learn that then you you know
you can gamify it if
you begin not to take yourself
seriously exactly that's the levity
piece yeah i agree i agree
begin not to take yourself seriously um
you begin to see well you know what
purpose you know
it's like you set whatever purpose you
like you know uh
and so it's like you know we we grow up
thinking that you know there is purpose
and meaning and so on and so forth and
you realize
like no you're the one setting all of
that so you set your
script properly you set your script amen
you set your script one more time
you you set your script script
however you should be aware from where
the script
is is coming from you are talking about
the source exactly
where does from where does the script
arrive beautiful
beautiful from words yeah yeah
yeah and and when there's [ __ ] up
scripts in there
man because it's [ __ ] up it's 100
your ability 100 you can
like you said contemplate what is
written in there and um
go through the experiential practices
there's all these modalities
for for that that exists now ted
yes okay that last last thing yeah good
don't believe in what you think right
i have this thing i always say um
and this would be a good end to your our
podcasts here yes yes
don't think feel
yeah don't feel be
right so don't think
that you are love don't feel that you're
in love
be loved be it
and then we just butterfly effect that
out
all over i love that i love it
that's the logo of home boat by the way
yes it is
yeah i know i know